have you ever heard about zhong shenshin
at the end of 2020
zhong shenshan actually became the
richest person in asia
with a net worth of 77.8 billion dollars
his net worth didn't just stop right
there either in january of 2021
shenzhen would reach a peak net worth of
95 billion dollars
since then his net worth has cooled off
quite substantially
as he now sits at the high 60 billion
mark but
given that he was at just 2 billion a
year ago i don't think he's complaining
the first assumption
i had when i read about this was that
shenzhen likely founded china's next
tech or manufacturing giant
but in reality chance's wealth doesn't
come from selling high margin software
or high volume consumer goods no
shenshin
actually made his fortune selling
bottled water wait a minute
this makes no sense a bottled water
company founder is wealthier than the
founders of alibaba
tencent and foxconn and he made most of
us wealth in a single year
clearly there's more going on here than
what meets the eye
so here's the story of how zhongshan
chen really became asia's richest person
by just selling water
before we get into shenzhen's story
let's first lay out some context as to
how absurd this achievement is
the beverage industry is basically
impossible to break into
due to insulin low profit margins and
how much of a stronghold the market
leaders have
just take a look at the most popular
boiled water companies such as aquafina
dasani nestle waters and smart water
aside from nestle waters which is
obviously made by nestle
the other brands don't seem to be
associated with large conglomerates
though their name doesn't suggest such a
relationship aquafina is actually owned
by pepsi
the sauna is owned by coca-cola and
smart water is owned by energy brands
which is owned by coca-cola
pepsi and coca-cola basically owned the
beverage industry
mainly because they were the first
people there so it's no wonder why kevin
o'leary
obliterates every beverage company that
makes its way onto shark tank
with all of that being said let's take a
look at how shenshin defied the odds
starting off shenzhen was born in
hangzhou china in 1954.
we've heard of top billionaires dropping
out of college and sometimes even high
school
but chanchin actually dropped out of
elementary school at the age of 12.
unlike other billionaires though he
didn't drop out to start his own
business
he was actually forced to drop out
because of the cultural revolution
the cultural revolution was a massive
communist led uprising within china
designed to purge a country of
capitalists during the revolution
all economic activity was halted and
hundreds of thousands of people would
die
unfortunately shanson's parents would be
one of the people that were persecuted
by the authorities
so education was one of the last things
on shenzhen's mind
and he would find a rather
uncontroversial job in construction
throughout his teenage years
right after the cultural revolution
ended in 1976 though
shenzhen would be quick to go to college
at the zhejiang radio and tv university
where he studied chinese this degree led
to him picking up a job as a journalist
at jjing daily
up until 1988 till this point shenzhen
had mainly just worked on getting by
and making sure he had food on the table
however as economic restrictions became
looser in the 1980s
shenzhen would start his first business
in 1988.
this business was a very simple grocery
business that chin chin ran
at a tourist island named hainan he
ended up selling mushrooms
prawns and turtles to tourists and
locals but this effort didn't last too
long
we aren't exactly sure why he gave up
this local business
but shenzhen would end up getting
another job this time he worked as a
sales agent at the wahaha beverage
company
and this is where he would get the idea
to start his own beverage company
you see bottled water was and still is
extremely popular within china
and for good reason unlike the us where
i still have no idea as to why people
buy bottled water
in china natural water sources are
oftentimes heavily polluted
due to significant amounts of
manufacturing activity also
the sewage and water treatment
facilities in china are quite terrible
not to mention many of the water pipes
in china were installed before 1968
and the pipes have significantly rusted
since then so
drinking tap water in china is a serious
health risk as it often contains large
amounts of bacteria
viruses chlorine lead mercury aluminum
and who knows what else
given the undrinkable nature of tap
water basically all of china had
resorted to buying bottled water
and more specifically distilled bottled
water now distilled water
is perfectly safe to drink but it does
like to dissolve minerals that regular
clean drinking water has
this includes minerals like calcium and
magnesium which are actually beneficial
for health
in the 1990s china had plenty of
distilled water brands
but it seemed like no one was offering
simple clean drinking water with
minerals and this is precisely what
shenzhen would target
in 1996 shenzhen would found a bottled
water company
which would eventually become non-food
spring their primary
marketing pitch was that unlike the rest
of the industry they didn't remove
natural minerals from the water
given that the chinese people were
already a bit worried about just
drinking distilled water with no
minerals
non-fu springs took off after this major
success
non fu springs would go ahead and launch
a variety of food drinks in 2003.
non-food springs did specifically target
teenagers with these food drinks
and they did try to craft some unique
marketing material but
by this point the brand image is what
was really propelling known foo forward
within china nang fu springs became
known as the up and coming beverage
company that was more natural
and healthier than the rest and this
perception allowed them to roll out a
handful of new products over the next
decade
including vitamin water in 2010
sugar-free tea in 2011
milk tea in 2012 orange and apple juice
in 2016
and most recently coffee in 2019. in the
meantime
they have also expanded their water
production to pull water from 10
different natural sources throughout
china
and even one in new zealand aside from
expanding their product lineup
shenzhen has also placed significant
emphasis on marketing to grow the
business
one notable instance of covered product
placement was during the 2016 g20 leader
summit
shenshin was able to get non-ful water
into the event and
president xi obama putin trudeau and
many others
would end up sipping the mineral rich
water throughout the event
similarly in 2017 nang fu would spend 18
million dollars to become the
telesponsor
of the first season of rap of china this
was of course an effort to appeal to
china's youth
anyway through such clever marketing
moves and positioning in the marketplace
shenzhen was successfully able to break
into the bottled water industry
and grown ngongfu springs into a
multi-billion dollar business
while growing his personal wealth to two
billion dollars by 2020.
so that's the more natural part of
shenzhen's business success
of course he always had the blessings of
the ccp as you can't achieve any sort of
business success in china
without that but in 2020 shenzhen would
transition from just being on the good
side of the ccp
to being their star child over the years
the ccp
has had a very complicated relationship
with billionaires and business tycoons
within the country as the name of the
party suggests
they are communist and they believe in
communist ideologies
this includes the idea that all property
is publicly owned and that each person
works and is paid according to their
abilities
and needs ideally there would be no
billionaires or business moguls in such
a system
and that's how it was in the 1950s and
1960s
but since the death of mao zedong the
ccp has gone looser
and looser when it comes to the economy
you see the ccp realized in the 1970s
and 80s
that they couldn't continue to limit
economic freedom if they wanted to grow
into a world power so they started
letting people open businesses which
grew china's economic output
and allowed them to compete on a world
stage don't let this freedom fool you
though
billionaires in china are hand-picked by
the ccp and
closely monitored to ensure that these
billionaires don't step out of line
if they do step out of line and oppose
the ccp or try to flee the country
the ccp will be sure to take appropriate
action many people like to speculate
that nefarious things happen to these
billionaires
but we're not going to go down that road
in this video if you guys are interested
in this topic
then be sure to check out jake tran's
video on the subject what we can confirm
though
is that the businesses of billionaires
who step out of line will be punished
with restrictive regulation
and litigation meanwhile billionaires
who are on the good side of the ccp
will be blessed with loose regulation
and aid from the government
and it seems like zhong shenshan just
replaced jack ma as the star child of
the ccp
if you guys didn't know jack ma founded
alibaba and used to be china's richest
man
however in late october he would make
some remarks the ccp
weren't big fans of and after this he
would go missing for three months before
making a low key return
and laying low ever since a striking
difference between jack ma
and zhong shenshen is their
personalities jack ma
is extremely charismatic and outspoken
while shenshin is extremely reserved and
quiet
maybe the ccp realized that they
shouldn't bet on outspoken individuals
like jack ma
when it comes to representing the elite
class of china and this
is where things get interesting after
jack ma's comments
on november 13 2020 president xi would
go ahead
and personally stop the ipo of ant group
which is another company founded by jack
ma
and on this exact same day non food
stock would start to pump
after two months of stagnation within
the next two trading days
non food stock would rally 20 percent
but here's the thing
there was no new news from non fu no
press releases
no new products no earnings reports
nothing
and guess what this pump was exactly
enough to get zhongshan chen to overtake
jack ma
as china's reached man on november 17th
2020.
after this pump though the stock would
go back into stagnation mode for the
next month
between december 15th and january 8th
though nang fu spring stock would roar
upwards
once again growing a massive 50 within
weeks
but once again there was no major news
coming out from non-food during this
time period
either there was however massive news
coming out about jack ma
between december 13th and december 31st
every news organization was busy
covering how jack ma had lost billions
and how he didn't even attend his own
talent show we saw headlines like
how china lost patience with jack ma its
loudest billionaire
jack ma's wealth tumbles by 12 billion
dollars in two months
as china seeks to shrink the
billionaire's financial empire jack ma
disappears from his own talent show
and so on and so forth at the exact same
time
we also saw articles describing how
zhongshan chin just became the richest
person
in asia it almost seems like wealth was
being transferred from jack ma
to zhong and that zhang's rights to the
top was being used to produce news
coverage surrounding jack ma's
disappearance
it doesn't just stop right there either
at the end of january
jack ma would make a return and suddenly
all of a song's new found wealth would
disappear shortly after
as non-food stocks crashed from 65 a
share back down to 40
a share exactly where it was in
september and october
and during this entire fall there were
no negative news pieces coming out about
gnongfu
i mean if you just take a look at the
stock graph it does seem like a pump and
dump
and keep in mind this is not a company
like tesla or apple that's fueled by
hype
this is a water bottle company now this
isn't to say that non-food is not a
legitimate company
or that zong didn't work extremely hard
to build non-fu into a multi-billion
dollar conglomerate
but more recently it does seem like
there's more happening than what meets
the eye
what do you guys think about song's
journey to the top comment that down
below
also drop a like if you guys found this
analysis rather intriguing
and of course consider joining our
discord community to suggest future
video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari hurry i'll see
you guys on the next one